what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with dark crisis technically
speaking it's dark crisis on infinite
Earths now but uh this is the main event
right this is the the thing that we've
been building up to all this time now
instead of covering dark crisis number
one we're actually going to cover the
deadly green which gives us like this
full understanding of what the great
darkness is actually capable of in terms
of its power as well as why it's
actually doing what it's doing because
the crazy thing about this is this takes
everything we understand about what the
great darkness is doing and why and
totally turns it on its head so one of
the first things to understand is that
technically this comic came out after
the events of dark crisis number one but
in reality it's self-contained so you
could really put it anywhere so we're
gonna put it here because it's just
really really cool and I think it sets
the stage better for dark crisis but
what this does is it basically opens up
with you could call it the new Justice
League if you want to kind of the
remnants of the Justice League because
the traditional Justice League was
defeated by pariah right we call that or
we we covered that the last video that
we did where they're basically out of
the picture now right so Kalel Superman
Bruce Wayne Batman Wonder Woman those
guys they're not here anymore right all
you have are just kind of their
descendants right or other members of
The League that are really more Reserve
members than anything else but what ends
up going on is that you do have the Hall
of Justice which is kind of like the
main meeting place of the Justice League
but below the Hall of Justice is
actually where you have a kind of
meeting place of all the various magical
people in DC Comics or at least the most
prominent ones and so that's why you
have like Dr Fate you have Raven now as
for these two swamp things you do have
the original right Alec Holland he's the
old school Swamp Thing the one that you
think of when you think of Swamp Thing
Levi I think is how you pronounce his
name is the new kid on the scene right
it's basically an instance where DC was
trying to bring in a new Swamp Thing to
kind of see how people might respond to
it it's basically a guy from India who
eventually started tapping into the
green and basically became another
version of Swamp Thing out there but the
important and really the significance
here when it comes to this is really
Alan Scott himself and one of the things
to know is that yes Alan Scott is a
Green Lantern but he's also not at the
same time when it comes to Green
Lanterns and DC Comics
99.999 meaning basically all of them
except for Alan Scott get your Green
Lantern ring in the traditional way
meaning that it Taps into the emotion of
willpower it's your Kyle Rayners your
Hal Jordan's those guys you know all
that kind of stuff with uh Alan Scott it
was a little bit different Alan Scott
was the result of DC trying to take his
character the way he existed in the
1940s when he basically got a Green
Lantern ring that was more based on
Magic and rolling it in so even now he
is a member of the Green Lantern Corps
but the nature of his ring is different
but the reason why this matters is
because when it comes to things like the
great darkness and DC Comics what Joshua
Williamson and DC have been doing here
is establishing the great Darkness as a
sort of yin to the presence's yang right
that the presence in the great Darkness
are two sides of the same coin seemingly
equal in power but standing for two
opposing forces right the great Darkness
you wouldn't really call it evil you
would simply call it just the absence of
anything and the presence represents the
existence of everything right light and
life you know versus darkness and
nothingness if you want to call it that
but the thing behind this is that when
it comes to the great Darkness because
so much of its storytelling is rooted in
the old swamping stories I think it was
like Swan thing number 50 back in the
day which was a tie end of crisis on
infinite nurse you know so on and so
forth a lot of the stories that you see
involving the great Darkness largely
deal with magic and DC isn't really
deviating away from that if anything
they're kind of expanding the great
Darkness beyond the confines of magical
storytelling and because it's permeating
every facet of the Multiverse now it's
affecting all the non-magical stuff as
well but the reason why this is so
significant is because with Alan Scott's
ring representing light and life being a
magically based ring it's the means by
which they can access the great Darkness
because they don't have a traditional
method to do that Pariah was really the
only means to achieve that right you'd
have to literally teleport to Multiverse
2 and then find some way to find a crack
in the Multiverse and then enter into
the great Darkness what Alan Scott's
ring does and what magic does is it
literally gives you a shortcut here's
the caveat to this if they go into the
Ring of Alan Scott and they use the
magic to access the great Darkness it
would overtake them immediately and so
what this does is it serves two purposes
because of the fact that Alan Scott's
son obsidian literally has powers tied
to the darkness which is basically an
aspect of the great Darkness itself
albeit not an immensely powerful that
what it does is it creates a bridge it
allows them to enter into the ring and
then using the darkness of obsidian's
power which will be used to infiltrate
the ring then it'll allow them kids to
communicate with the great Darkness or
at least access it right so imagine the
great Darkness speaks Spanish and the
powers of obsidian is a translator
that's basically what this is right it's
essentially what's going on here now
what they also need are people who can
withstand the corruption of the darkness
which is not an easy to do thing and so
that's why Jonathan Kent Raven and
basically the two swamp things merge and
enter into the ring and what happens
when they arrive is they're immediately
beset by the power of Alan Scott and
what's literally going on here is the
ring and even Alan Scott's willpower is
trying to fight off the power of the
darkness while they're trying to access
it now that'll become an important
feature later on down the line but the
truth about this is the power of the
great darkness is one of physical power
right like it's wildly capable in terms
of what it can do overtaking
ridiculously powerful characters you
know when it took over Darkseid Right
Dark Side never had a chance against the
power of the great darkness and in fact
Winnie entered into it he was
immediately overwhelmed and literally
taken prisoner right because it was like
trying to fight smoke there was nothing
he could do there it was so far beyond
him but the other power of the great
darkness is seeding doubt is seeding
fear in the minds of the people who come
into contact with it and what also
happens is once they enter into this
ring of course Jonathan Kent tries to
fly off and enter into this this black
Citadel which essentially houses or at
least is the vector point the means by
which they can directly communicate with
the great Darkness but his powers don't
work right his powers have literally
just kind of been cut off here now we're
not given a direct explanation why it
could simply be because he's in a realm
composed entirely of magic and Superman
along with Jonathan Kent are weak to
Magic it could be because it's just the
fact that his powers don't work here
maybe there's no yellow sun or even just
the great darkness by virtue of the
power of obsidian is keeping his powers
basically neutralized whatever the case
happens to be they end up basically
moving forward and have to travel on
foot and that's where the doubt really
begins to come into play that's where
the doubt really begins to sort of Feed
in because as they're walking along when
it comes to Raven they start questioning
whether or not she's the reason why
they're not able to use their abilities
and why it is that they end up walking
in circles because one of the things
they realize is that as they move along
they end up encountering like the same
vehicle they keep seeing the same things
so they're basically walking in circles
right they're going nowhere and even the
form of Swamp Thing kind of starts to
revert and turn into its human form now
the reality of this and what Raven
initially tries to say is this is not of
my doing but the great Darkness the the
dark negative energy is basically
infiltrating and penetrating both
Superman and Swamp Thing and what they
end up doing is turning on Raven now
here's the reason why this matters is
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with the character of Raven because this
needs to be explained when it comes to
Raven herself she's the daughter of
Trigon Trigon is one of the most
powerful evil entities in all of DC
Comics but something to understand and
what DC has been doing here with the
with regards to the dark crisis event
they've been establishing this no notion
that beings like dark side and like
necron who leads the Black Lantern Corps
basically the lanterns of the undead
people like Trigon and so on and even
Lucifer himself they don't just exist
out there as beings that represent evil
they are all in some form or fashion an
avatar or someone who represents the
power of the great darkness and that's
really the extent of how Grand the power
of the great darkness is and in fact
we'll talk more about that here in a
second because Constantine was one of
the guys who went with him but you'll
notice the Constantine's not here we'll
actually find out what's going on with
him because that's where we really get
some cool storytelling going on here but
that's kind of the nature of this it's
because Raven is so intertwined with
quote unquote Darkness or evil if you
want to call it that that their thought
is she's the reason why their powers
don't work or the reason why they're
walking in circles or something along
those lines right she's making her move
or she's a villain now it doesn't make
any sense it's completely illogical and
that's not arbitrary in fact it's
designed to show us how corrupted
they're becoming by the power of the
great darkness that it twists and screws
up everything it meets and in fact they
become so corrupted that they start
attacking Raven they start going after
her like trying to destroy her now
ultimately she ends up using her power
to basically subdue Jonathan Kent and
sort of free him from this corruption
he's experiencing now the kind of
corruption that they're getting is
relative to the to the individual person
in the instance of Jonathan Kent he
lives under the shadow of his father
Khalil and so his big fear and big
concern is he'll never live up to the
man that his father was but when Raven
is able to basically subdue that fear
able to hold it at Bay and really
convince Jonathan you're your own man
right like be your own hero it kind of
cures him of this corruption to a degree
and that's when he tells Swamp Thing no
no no Raven is actually here to save us
and that's when Raven really reveals
that's why the three of us are here
Constantine was supposed to be here and
I have no idea where Constantine is but
you Jonathan Ken are here because you
represent kind of Earth's link between
humanity and what Superman stands for
because you're one half human one half
Kryptonian from an idealistic standpoint
Superman is everything Humanity could
become right the greatness of what
Humanity could truly achieve if it put
its problems aside and started focusing
on becoming better as a whole as an
actual group as opposed to people
functioning on a selfish and
individualistic level you Swamp Thing
represent light and life on Earth
because you're tied to all living things
more nature and plants than anything
else but still you represent the kind of
sum total of life on Earth because it's
by way of oxygen-rich giving plants and
oxygen-rich giving trees and so on that
life can even flourish in the first
place I Raven him here because I've been
so close to the dark my entire life has
always been one breath away from being
corrupted by trygan and because of that
I am entrenched in understanding the
dark so that's why I am your guide right
that's why I'm here in order to assist
you guys and to help you guys get to
your destination and it's one of the
things that's really interesting because
as they finally get to where the tower
is Raven's like I can't go any further
right I can't move any further because
if I do if I enter into that Tower I
will immediately become corrupted by the
great Darkness because with the light
and life that you guys have you can
fight it off for a little while then it
would be far easier for the great
Darkness to corrupt me than it would be
for it to corrupt you so you two have to
go in now the reality here is that on an
individual level if Jonathan and Swamp
Thing enter in there they'll be
corrupted relatively fast and in fact
faster than they can achieve their goal
because even on their own they simply
can't enter in there because the power
of the darkness is so great that it
actually starts to override the very
light that they possess right their
goodness you know so to speak and so
what Swamp Thing does is propose a
situation where it says because you
Jonathan Kent are one half human I
represent everything that is you right
that makes you who you are so let's
merge right let's combine our forces
together and basically Jonathan can't
become Swamp Thing and it looks amazing
right it looks really really cool to see
and it's a it's a phenomenal like it's
phenomenal outfit for these characters
to have now the other part of this and
something that I also want to point out
here is Alan Scott himself right like
out there in the real world where you
have Alan Scott literally operating as a
vector by which Superman or Jonathan and
Raven and Swamp Thing are inside the
ring that Alan Scott is in really uh
instinctively fighting against the power
of the great Darkness what this does is
it warps the world inside the ring and
that's what makes everything seem so
chaotic and everything so hodgepodge is
because it's literally a kind of War
taking place inside the ring that can't
readily be seen with normal human eyes
and so what happens is Jade and obsidian
approach Alan Scott and say you have to
stop fighting right like I will not let
the darkness permeate any more than it
needs to but you have to stop fighting
because if you do one you're gonna burn
yourself out and you're literally going
to die and two it's will likely lead to
the death of Jonathan and Superman and
Raven in them because the world will
become too unstable and too chaotic for
them to exist in and so when Alan Scott
immediately stops that's when everything
starts to find some measure of balance
right it's basically like uh being
inside the eye of a hurricane right or
the ending of a storm the wind stops
blowing the trees stop rustling the
roofs of the houses stop blowing off and
everything finds some measure of
equilibrium and so what happens is with
Jonathan and Swamp Thing entering into
basically The Dark Tower or at least
accessing a portion or at least a
version of the great Darkness what it
does is it allows them to realize that
what they found here and what's lodged
inside the great darkness is the
antimatter projector of
well it's really more the antimatter
chamber than the projector but the fact
is that before the events of crisis on
infinite Earth and what triggered the
original crisis event was basically
Pariah trying to witness the birth of
the universe and running a quote-unquote
experiment through the antimatter
chamber what that did is it woke up the
anti-monitor and then the anti-monitor
started going through and wiping out the
Multiverse which started the original
crisis on infinite Earth's event exactly
what role this chamber will play in the
greater dark crisis event has yet to be
seen and in fact we'll I mean we'll see
it play out as time goes on we just
simply don't know what it is within this
story but it is significant enough that
it allows them to grab the antimatter
chamber and then basically leave now
this is when we switch over to what's
going on with John Constantine so when
Swamp Thing and Jonathan and Raven were
whisked away into the realm of the Ring
what had happened is Constantine was
supposed to show up there instead
Constantine was snatched away by the
great darkness and in fact the great
Darkness starts to communicate directly
with Constantine now this is where
things get really really interesting
here because again one of the things
that we've reiterated here is the great
darkness is not really evil right it
doesn't really represent evil and in
fact it says that to Constantine right
like it says I am not really an evil
being per se and so this conversation is
wildly interesting right because the
great Darkness manifests in different
forms you never actually see it because
the great darkness is not a particular
being it's really more of a presence or
a source of energy but when it manifests
it says things up here Bleak this time
don't they John all this humor and
bravado you're only putting on a brave
face and it says well you sought out the
great Darkness John Constantine so speak
and Constantine asked the question why
have you why has the great Darkness
returned why now and the response that
it offers is no no you've got it all
wrong John have I really returned or
have I only been waiting for the lights
to go out and for the show to begin I.E
have I always been here and you're only
just now seeing me right it says it is
only in my presence that you are free to
be who you really are and then it turns
into try again and it says and the truth
always lies at the extremes do we really
know if Jonathan Kent can live up to his
father's Legacy if it's not in the face
of darkness is Levi deserving of the
trust his world has put in him even in
this darkest hour and Raven is it not
only because of me that she strives so
hard to be anything else but herself and
it says here you are a minuscule thing
out in the dark still your vanity knows
no end I was here before everything do
you know what that even means the first
star an invisible twinkle from where you
now stand that was born in defiance of
me and yet it has long dwindled out in
my memory and so where you had
Constantine that made this argument and
said that like superheroes intrinsically
understand the extremes right they
understand what it truly means to fall
to their darker side and what would
happen if they did Superman knows what
would happen if he turned evil but he
also understands that he has to strive
against that and become the better
version of himself he'll never be
ultimately good because that part of him
that just wants to kill all the
criminals in the world and force
everybody to be good is always there and
it's always pulling so the best he can
do is find a middle ground but the funny
thing is the great Darkness says to
stand in the face of timelessness and
think that you are being tested like a
raft in a storm thinking an ocean exists
to test its metal the truth of the
matter John Constantine is that my
eternal existence is the canvas against
which you play out your struggles
without knowing where the edges lie how
could you possibly fathom the middle you
have opened my hand seeking answers and
found it to be empty what the great
darkness is basically saying here is
every dark desire that exists out there
every instance or every feeling that
Superman has where it's like you know I
could kill Lex Luthor or every instance
where Batman's like maybe I should kill
the Joker right every time they have
that feeling that's the great Darkness
right the great darkness is the part of
all existence every living creature
every sentient creature that has a
desire to fall to their base or
instincts to fall to their evil and
darker side that's the great darkness
and that's the pull that they're always
trying to avoid that's what it means
when it says that my eternal existence
is the canvas against which you play out
your struggles now it also goes on and
it says it is your own hubris that has
brought you here the corruption like me
was always at the heart of you and as I
have countless instances of life that
litter all of time I shall watch you
undo it and Glory or I shall watch it be
your undoing I.E in the end Constantine
will ultimately end up destroying
himself now I don't really think that
this is an instance where DC is saying
like this is how things are going to
unfold right Constantine's death is
going to happen in like five issues it's
not really what DC's saying here it's
simply just this idea that Constantine
always has this extreme inner Darkness
right this extreme part of him that is
incredibly violent and Incredibly evil
and a time will come when he will give
in to that and when it happens he'll end
up destroying himself in the process but
the caveat and what's really interesting
here is Constantine in the great
Darkness are watching everything that
goes on with Jonathan and Swamp Thing
and Raven and so when they get their
hands on the antimatter chamber and when
they're able to basically make their
escape without being corrupted by the
great Darkness the response of
Constantine is do you see now right I'm
not usually one to get all emotional
about goodness and light and hope and
all that other nonsense I've been around
long enough to know better all that
power dressed in costumes and pageantry
to hide unstable creatures trying to
find some measure of normalcy in this
life Laden with the responsibility of
knowing but without the excuse of
helplessness this is what they are at
the extremes but in the middle the
boring and mundane middle they're just
normal people Constantine tells the
great darkness and says you've been
watching us for so long you should know
by now in the darkness people will
eventually always find their way and
that's when the Great darkness turns
into Lucifer Morningstar now this is the
power of the great Darkness right this
is just how powerful the great darkness
is a lot of people ask this question who
would win in a fight Lucifer Morningstar
or the great Darkness the great Darkness
right by more than a little bit and
here's the reason why I say that during
the original crisis on infinite Earth's
event when you were focusing on the Alan
Moore vertigo side which we might go
back and cover that to be honest because
it'd be really cool to cover here in
fact I think we will but in that story
there was a point where Lucifer
Morningstar ended up striking a deal to
to basically ensure the survival of him
and others like him in the face of the
great Darkness that's how powerful this
guy is not even Lucifer Morningstar can
overcome the great darkness and he's
second to God in the DC Universe now
again God is kind of equal to the great
darkness and the great darkness is equal
to God right the presence so again
everybody else is secondary and that
when you have the great Darkness turning
into Lucifer Morningstar which really is
a throwback to the old Swamp Thing
stories from the original crisis event
it says there you go blaming me again
John Constantine when all I've done is
call you down here for a chat it says so
I offer you a retort I know your
capacity for ephemeral greatness if only
for a moment you are deserving of the
love and adulation bestowed upon you but
all the time you've been in existence
have I ever looked upon life with
anything but Fascination don't you see I
sit here in the black for all eternity
your liquor is the only light I get now
this is an enormous Revelation I know it
doesn't seem like it but it's a massive
Revelation here and the reason why is
because when the when the antimatter
chamber is found by Jonathan and Raven
and Swamp Thing That John Constantine
looked at that and says that's pariah's
machine isn't it it's him he's the
fulcrum of all of this and the response
to the great darkness is I have given
you all the answers you'll have for me
Constantine I hope that you will
remember this favor before the next
event arrives and you come knocking upon
my door again I hope you will know that
I am by my very nature incapable of hate
if anything I am the greatest romantic
you'll ever meet now this is why it's so
important because the great Darkness as
it's been shown in Justice League
Frontier and with all the stories we've
done death of the Justice League and all
that kind of stuff it seems like this
kind of omnipotent indestructible evil
force that exists out there when it
takes on the form of Lucifer Morningstar
it gives it just this whole new Dynamic
and this whole new personality the
reality here is the great Darkness has
no desire to conquer everything the
great Darkness has no desire to end all
of creation and it never really did it
never had a desire to do that instead
what had happened here and we'll learn
more about this in the in the main dark
crisis story then instead Pariah got his
hands on the great darkness and it's
Pariah who's the focal point Pariah is
the one who's using the great Darkness
for his own scheme and his own goal the
great Darkness itself is really just a
source of power so it's not the great
darkness is trying to end everything and
it's not the great Darkness behind all
this it's Pariah him and him alone but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace